hi my name is Alaina and I'm a makeup
artist if you like my makeup makeup look
thank you for watching
to start with I'm using this Clinique
Moisture Surge to give my skin a little
bit I'm gonna leave this on for five
minutes before starting my makeup now
I'm going to take the spam minerals
primer and apply it all over my face to
fill in my pores and Brad to my skin
this complexion well is quite like a
tinted moisturizer as it gives a little
coverage I like to toss it around my
face for an even matte finish I use this
concealer under my eyes and around any
blemishes that I have I like to use my
fingers after so it gives me the most
natural look
[Music]
when doing a no makeup makeup look I
like to use a clear brow gel as I felt
though this gives me the most natural
appearance I'm using the applicator in
an upward motion to give my brows fuller
look I'm applying this black mascara to
lift my lashes and I'm only applying it
to the top of my lashes as far as those
not as heavy I'm applying this perfect
pink lip balm to add a slight tint and
also hydrate my lips this is a gel
blusher in the color anymore and I like
to apply it with my fingers as it gives
me a natural glow for more videos like
this subscribe to glamming UK's YouTube
channel
[Music]